you're working in conjunction with tick
tock on there so why are you doing that
yeah it's called Tick Tock freak it's a
full ep it's going to probably be the
first EP ever distributor on The Tick
Tock platform as a partnership because I
realized that my catalog was getting so
many streams on Tick Tock and a song
that I had released before my first or
everyone thought was my first single
locked up Bonanza had become such a huge
huge thing and I said man this could be
an opportunity to get you know more
engaged with my younger fans and younger
generation but at the same time allow me
to get that perfect window to come back
to doing what I love which was music
well yeah and there are happy been songs
that have gone viral because of doing so
well on Tick Tock how much of a
difference you think social media is
playing now and getting music heard and
out there social media is is like I mean
the impact is tremendous I've never seen
anything like it you know because I
remember back when I was coming up we
literally had to go from radio station
to radio station to radio station to
Club to record store like we literally
had to go to every single specific you
know location personally now I can do
everything stream from my phone in the
whole world get it so it made life so
much as well isn't it that's the only
thing it allows for it to be super
transparent everybody get the same exact
chance so it makes it very convoluted
very it's a lot of traffic as far as
artists and talent and content creators
now yeah and is that an extra challenge
not just writing the music but also
staying relevant being on the right
platforms getting heard how much of a
challenge are you finding that now
um well with me it's not much of a
challenge because I've kind of built an
audience based before the actual the
bang but I know for a lot of newer
artists it takes a lot longer to get
recognized unless you have some kind of
marketing you know genius around you
understand the way that you just got to
be super creative and different and
you've got your own label haven't you so
you know all about right some of those
newer acts coming in to the to the scene
I also use the platform to look for new
talent and even find ways to find better
and different ways to do things that
I've always had love to do for and yet
you've also worked with some incredible
established artists as well haven't you
Eminem David Guetta you also worked of
course with Lady Gaga didn't you yeah
and that was way back when that was yeah
did you did you know when you when you
first worked with her just how big she'd
be no I mean the moment I saw her and
laid eyes on I knew she was a star it
was like whoa like who's that and then
when I saw her actually singing in the
booth I was like she's just she's going
to be the future for sure and there are
many other people that you've had that
same experience with yes man there's so
many
when I go back and think about how many
artists that we discovered or worked
with I mean the list just goes on and on
I think you know that was probably my
gift here was just kind of utilize my
celebrity and give other people a chance
to actually become who they truly
supposed to be can you put your finger
on what it is that you look for well me
today I look for hard workers
um before I used to just look for good
talent but then I realized that
everybody with Talent aren't really hard
workers and it takes a lot of work in
this business to take it to the next
level so the talent alone won't be able
to do it for you so many things I could
talk about with you today I do want to
touch on some of the comments you've
made about Kanye West right because he's
been in the news a lot a lot of
controversies including a Twitter ban
for anti-semitic comments he's been
banned Again by Elon Musk this morning
for inciting violence Elon abandon
apparently sir but but you've shown some
support from why have you done that well
because I'm I show support for you know
opinion and I think people will always
have in a specific opinion and I think
the moment we get to the place where we
close our minds up to other people's
opinion it kind of this it kind of
doesn't allow us to get to better know
each other better know our mindsets and
more than anything better than our
movements and I think sometimes we kind
of prejudge people from the way that we
may see or view things and I think
sometimes we should just open up our
minds let things play all the way out
and better understand the situation so
we have a better solution for it and I
know that you've said you don't agree
with his comments but if they're really
offensive will he still continue to back
him
yeah because I'm I'm I'm a backer of the
the right to believe what you want to
believe now Damien him have a
conversation I will give him my point of
view on why I disagree and then he may
come back and say you know what you're
right or he may come and say well I'm
not then I then at that point it's my
job to understand why he's viewing it
that way so I think conversation and
communication is always the key but
sometimes we block that out and you
never can get anywhere if you're not
communicating so it doesn't trouble you
that he makes really offensive comments
to many people not really because those
those comments don't really affect me
personally and I think if everyone takes
it that way then it's different and if
it does affect you personally then find
a way to actually respond in a way to
where that conversation can be you know
uh reciprocated because I think
sometimes when someone is offensive or
offended they just lash out in defense
or lash out to kind of make that person
feel the same offense that they felt and
I think you know when you when you take
negative and you you kind of apply the
response negatively back it never you
can only get Negative back so I think
it's really a matter of both sides
understanding what it is don't take
things too personal yet until you
understand the situation okay one other
subject we want to move on to which is
um very important is the World Cup right
you're here in the UK you were born in
America but you spent a lot of your
child in Senegal it's a place close to
your heart who are you going to be
supporting on Sundays what kind of
question is that man we're ready to beat
England's butts I think we've got our
answer so how are you spending your time
during the match uh I'm putting together
as a private party uh I'm actually in
London so it's going to be interesting
because I'm gonna probably be the only
English well non-english person in the
room you know but I I think it's going
to be all and fun though but I believe
that Senegal is going to win I'm
predicting 1-0 okay and and still
keeping an eye out for the us as well oh
yeah the US is man they you know what's
interesting I'm so proud of the US
because they came so far like within the
last five ten years you know what what
we call the soccer obviously but
football has been like almost Prime like
priority like we're selling out stadiums
now in major matches in every state in
America so it's like we we have a lot to
prove this year okay well have fun on
Sunday absolutely I would wish you good
luck but uh maybe maybe
good to meet you thanks very much